[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship
july 29 momenthouse.com tinymeatgang
tell them what we're doing we're doing
it's gonna be so much fun we got dj's
head from spock
we got a live that's cringe we're doing
a new cody noel do we're premiering it
no one's ever seen it we learned how to
sword fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and
we got some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
uh so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for
24 hours after the show happens so in
case you bought a ticket but you miss it
you can still watch it for the day after
but after that
this finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.comgang
i think we've talked all week and talk
about the first episode to be honest
no yeah i mean i think there's really
nothing left but to
do what we need to do let's make our
character and the love let's bring
kodo into the new season shall we of the
love ireland game so we'd be at season
four everybody wow season four coming
soon why wouldn't they start at the same
time as the
as the show fail bro oh because it's the
american one probably
maybe do we need to wait nah [ __ ] that
let's play season three
we never did season three no we didn't
hit it um by the way
you might as well just go ahead and load
up on those gems
run that card run it dude use the use
the business card
all right yeah that [ __ ] hit let's go to
season three baby
oh it crashed nice nice yeah
thank you fuse box
oh you remember noah oh yeah dork
librarian what a nerd man i wish season
four was
so you play games yeah
all right stick the landing we don't
even care
here we go the villa has a new cr it's
the
whatever let's hit that play button yeah
hit the play button let's go
we got to make it we got to make us
we're going to make our character
here we go again indeed here we go
you know what's crazy is that well you
know what actually
you just save it what what are you about
to say oh just some inside baseball
stuff
not important yeah here's the villa yeah
we have to like my orca we got it now we
gotta i hope there's a
blast off station from here yeah that's
not a beam no there is
there is okay yeah so like we gotta
commute every week to back to
no no no that's how that's why you know
getting here was so easy because we were
able to fly over
drop down and this is that little town
that's like about like an hour away from
here
okay so we can go there yeah okay yeah
perfect
we're actually it was crazy we're at the
villa and all the people are still
inside like they just keep them inside
until we're done with the show and then
we
just keep filming so it's crazy because
you know in one way you could say that
you know we're not really afraid of the
people that we're talking about because
they're literally right there
20 steps exactly we're talking that [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's right gumby you heard
me
with the door locked all right let's
let's get this forward
how are you supposed to have time for we
we know what this is man
let's make our lady yeah just just crush
it fast forward right until the [ __ ]
character
you've been invited to a place where
everyone gets to know each other and
[ __ ]
a place called love island welcome back
to love island
choose your appearance okay here we go
here we go let's go
your wardrobe close
uh x all right go to the left oh none of
the right sorry
one more this is us that's us this is
that bronze
yes codell yes it is with the red head i
can't believe we're bringing her back
we just now go to eyes codel got her
beautiful green eyes
uh oh yeah check check
green green
like emeralds um the nose and lips
nose make it a sick nose yeah i don't
know how you
i mean it's all kind of the same go to
the one on the right yeah no
that one yep now cuddle's nose is a
little bit thinner
yep yeah that's the right one i think
lips are fine
luscious lips
put that red hair right back yeah yep
yep yep yep oh
no let's go orange let's go let's be a
ginge
that's what's that's what she's yeah she
was got red red you're right
yep go go to red again go to red let's
get this right
that's no that's brown is that brown
yeah we want
yeah we need the fire yes yes yes yes we
need to make a statement here folks yeah
orange yeah
i'll just listen to that those are good
lashes
that bow burn themselves go back yeah
yeah that's solid
yeah where he's talking about sad things
in the world no
and then he just says i saw a boy who
was a ginger
oh yeah i saw black red hair
what's so [ __ ] up what do you want to
be cold
oh i think we know the answer to this
this name
c o d e l
so just like the first episode you know
we gotta
we just gotta um get in there wow
and get busy um so
this is the look this is the look
this is the look the look
no we've played before trust me we've
played before
what should i wear oh this is the best
part picking her clothes yeah
let's go um oh that orange one
one of the left kind of with the hair
i'm [ __ ] with the floral
okay you want the left yeah that [ __ ] is
like that kind of hits
you know it's a little la though yeah
but it like
accents the skin tone okay you know yep
yeah yeah okay i like the yeah
it draws attention to the to the runs
yeah
nature of this yeah burn those gems hot
15
do it unlock that skin
i look amazing you look amazing but i'd
say
look i'm actually by the way all the all
the you know
the ad money that we get from this like
from doing advertisements it's all going
into gems yeah it's all going to gems
next time this episode is going to have
9 billion gems
whatever couple hundred dollars we make
we're gonna put it all on gems
alright so we're gonna play this not on
we'll play in the background yeah like
we'll we'll we'll still do some
parts of the gameplay and then we'll
play some parts yeah that's that's why
we never finished it the first time
because if you actually sit there and
play it
it takes i don't know 16 17 hours and it
got like boring
yeah it was the same [ __ ] over and over
again we're like dude this is not gonna
this series is just not gonna
yeah um continue being nah cause it's
like it's like when you first meet the
characters and
yeah it's like the real love island kind
of gets boring like when they're
then they're actually coupled up and
everyone's in love then you're like ah
what happened yeah exactly it's like
near the end of the show it kind of gets
like a
so um but we're gonna keep playing it
and we'll clip it out and
and um yeah it'll be a segment on the
show
yeah so um
but i mean i think i think yeah i think
we've got it for this episode so next
week we'll
obviously recap what's going on in the
villa and we will play the game
um i know today your p people are like i
thought you're gonna [ __ ] play
we will play yeah we'll play um just not
this episode
yeah is that mean no messed up no i mean
this so we wanted to watch the show too
and and comment commentate not a word
not a word but
we wanted to commentate conversate about
the uh
the show because we watch it and it's on
every single day so there's
plenty of [ __ ] that goes down yeah we
the first episode was yesterday
second one's today and now it's on every
day until next week so we're gonna have
a ton of [ __ ] to talk about watch along
with us if you wanna
have fun listening to the show and we
hope you like the first episode we
appreciate
everyone all of you for joining us let
us know if there's anything you'd like
us to cover off
yeah that too we'd love to take you we'd
love to know opinions
take you for a ride yeah yeah it'd be a
really hot summer that's right in it
all right we gotta go uh unload our
trend and
beam up and beam up to the ship yeah